the heck is this kinda cheese
well I don't know anything about any
kaiser-jeep I get my first letter with
their hats probably tennis years old
what is it sure emo [ __ ] yeah
probably yeah my mistake
I forget this always that big song no
either this or everyday I love you less
and less no you're kidding me I remember
they had a very this chorus the chorus I
know this song and the law won yeah
that's the clash I thought the law send
me a copy of that state when I'm dying
to see you
the staircase is so great although the
three episodes could have been done in
one I didn't finish it yet it's okay but
I will I didn't love that whole he's
finally making a murder those last
couple episodes yeah you like got it
okay already know what's happening yeah
when he's like when you get to episode 8
and you're like he is guilty yeah that's
why I like to evil genius so much
because it's four episodes yeah and you
knock him out and it's all it's it's all
good even Rajneesh II yeah by the way I
think maybe one person on Instagram
figured out that the suit that I was
wearing to NXT takeover Chicago on the
net on the WWE Network was a bit of a
tip of the hat to the rajneeshees I told
you to put some orange in that I didn't
have any or on purpose or you're just a
horrible wardrobe owner first of all my
suit looks [ __ ] awesome look at this
the horrible wardrobe owner I look great
sure it looks great tie looks great it
should have some orange in there
and there is I should have worn an
orange like a pocket square yep just as
a little tip of the hat to the
rajneeshees
yeah like that's how I hate me I look
like a million bucks
no you really don't what no at least
however much you look like less than $30
no no no no I was gonna go at least six
hundred thousand yeah just some black
shoes
I don't wear sneakers in suits I think
it's tacky it's not
JD's Comicon evening at the end of now I
never wear sneakers and suits I think
it's yeah my sneakers do the talking in
my normal outfits but when I wear suits
I mean look at that suit you think you
need to compliment it anymore you know
what I mean
you come correct thanks bud how great
how great there's a Scott Baio is not
having assault charges filed by
prosecutors I'm guessing yeah that's a
timing issue yeah that's it didn't do it
that's just statute of limitation stuff
but how great is it that Chris
Hardwick's text messages and again now
unless there's a proof that or something
information she has that we do are not
privy to because again we can only talk
about what we had been told Hardwick
text message his response to her makes
it sounds like a pretty reasonable
[ __ ] way more than I've ever
been when ending a relationship well he
says long-ass text messages he did but
it was pretty reasonable and he yeah
somebody's printed that out hopefully a
bigger font it's a long one but it looks
like in his mind they had separated and
he felt she was cheating and still
seeing this person and he ended it
pretty definitively and I think the
bigger thing though more than JIT I mean
the break-up text is clearly just the
end of a relationship yes the thing
that's really damaging for her is that
not only did she text him over and over
and over and over again after he ended
months later but seven months later she
sent another we okay yet stop and it
looks from the screen grabs like he sent
this one breakup text and that was it it
looks like he just which I admire his
because no matter how bad an ending for
relationship is no matter how painful it
is but how devastating it is I a lot of
times I find myself unable to separate
from it right and you know even if she
was losing her mind a little bit when he
first sent her the text and just kept
texting him please no no no I'm like
okay I can still believe in like I think
Stockholm Syndrome is a thing stuff
right yeah yeah yeah but I found it to
be very damaging to her case that seven
months after the whole thing she texted
him again hey can we please make this
better and it's like if it was that
abusive it doesn't excuse the fact that
he
may have blackballed ur blackballing is
[ __ ] up but here's the bottom line
there's a physically abusing somebody or
beating somebody up if you're dating a
guy and you think the guy is just a dict
and [ __ ] leave if that's what this
one is shouting for because it annoys me
well wait did it annoys me that again if
he was blacklisting or he was truly
abusing her but if the guy if you're
dating someone who's just a dick because
what happens is people have shitty
relationships with people who turn out
to be [ __ ] and then that's getting
lumped in with people who are rapists
like that's lumped into the same
discussion it is as people who are
[ __ ] drugging women as people who are
holding a career over their head and
going [ __ ] me or I'm gonna ruin you
right those are different things
definitely what one is hey this is a guy
who might be too dominating but if you
say hey I left my ex girlfriend cuz she
didn't [ __ ] me enough okay that's not
the nicest thing to say to your
girlfriend and as a woman if a guy says
that to you you should go you know what
[ __ ] you buddy I'm taking off you should
yeah but I've stayed when I shouldn't
have stayed - that's why is this annoy
me because I've stayed when I knew
things were not the way I wanted them to
be and I'm a dumb [ __ ] sometimes
and I put myself through a tremendous
amount of pain but you know I didn't
have to you know when you're blaming
yourself though like you know when you
should be blaming like you know that did
it wasn't in your scenario somebody else
doing that to you that you should have
been a while know that I'm beginning I
tell you because I saw red flags at
times in my life I look back and I'll
see a red flag and I can remember
glossing over the red flag because I
didn't want it to be that way I wanted
it to be a different way and it just
wasn't and maybe that was the other
person's fault no I'm a [ __ ] grown
man right and I was older but it didn't
matter I'm an adult person and again if
you're in an abuse of horrible
physically abusive relationship you're
emotionally abusive that's the thing I
truly am oh yeah I guess so it can be a
thing sure but you do have the freedom
to walk away again I'm not talk about
the fear somebody beating you up is a
lot different than hey this guy is a guy
who I like to be with and he's an
[ __ ] and I'm staying with it so I
think that Bonnie's not listening to
this
here's to think I've stayed when I
shouldn't have stayed any time I think
he's in
covering that's where they've talked
about it like he's you know it's known
and I've said this before you know and
it's a cliche but people with our
background get comfortable in
uncomfortable situations that's what
we're used to chaos in our lives so you
get comfortable with it
so sometimes you're going well this is
my norm this uncomfortable so why would
I get out of it so I think that I think
that what I said yesterday was the fact
that she or not the fact that if he
blackballed her how do you blackballed I
mean I mean if you're Christmas and you
blackballed people yeah um but if that's
true then I could definitely give
credence to the argument that she was
afraid and wanted to stay in the
relationship the problem is that if
you're afraid somebody's gonna ruin your
career and you're out of the
relationship
you probably don't text them again seven
months later and try to get back in well
the thing is is and right and what type
of blacklisting was like if I was dating
somebody yeah and that person cheated on
me and we were involved professionally
and they wanted to do something I was a
part of I would tell whoever I was
working with I'm not working with that
person but would you say don't hire them
for anything I don't know if that's what
he said
I I'm only tell you what I would do I
would I say that no that's the
difference between blackballing and not
wanting to work with some yeah I don't
think that there's anything wrong with
not wanting to work with an act somebody
but if you're like let's say you used to
work even if you're not even a
relationship if you used to work with
somebody and a company it's like yeah I
want to bring them on I think if you go
I don't want to work with them that's
fine
but if you say I don't want you hiring
them for anything here it's [ __ ] up I
was a pretty reasonable sorry reg this
is the most reasonable breakup text I've
ever seen that's the longest day it is a
long one but it's the most reasonable
probably shoulda been an email breakup
text I've ever seen how many times you
think he wrote and rewrote it imagine if
his text app died vomited off [ __ ]
I'm gonna guess he's done what I've done
which was write it in a note app
whatever and then copy paste it and you
reread it a few times the last time I
had one of these
I sent an email after after I broke all
contact I sent an email which wasn't
horrible at all it was because I guess
if you're if you're texting and then you
start calling like oh that's stupid and
you're like delete delete send oh [ __ ]
that's why you don't want to do that
have you are blocking people is hard
it's nestled on your phone but it's hard
I never done it um yeah I've done it it
claim is hard to do
mentally it's hard mentally it's well
because that's really cutting out a
person in your life that you know on
Twitter it's easy as [ __ ] well that's
easy it's different you know I mean like
in a real village lowest thing you block
somebody through what if they're trying
to you know yeah block them or what yeah
they're not you black people on Twitter
rich I probably on the way there
bathroom I block five but like I don't
understand and and people look there are
so many creeps out here you know I mean
I was a creepy person back in the day I
never did against anybody's will is the
guy trying to get laid that's all you
still you're still creeped up yeah but
how are people losing careers without
isn't it innocent till proven guilty
well the problem is like AMC immediately
yanked his show and again like I said on
review I have to say I don't know
somebody said that there's proof to what
she says she said there's insert so did
one of her friends back to me said
there's photo and video and of course
her friends gonna back you I mean he
said he C but so we can only go by what
what yeah what they're telling us
but this breakup text is a [ __ ]
reasonable text and I know that there's
emotional abuse I'm not saying there's
not but I'm saying is seven months later
as a grown man I've stayed when I
shouldn't have stayed and I've stayed
because I wanted things to be different
and I wanted them to be better and I
didn't want them to be what I knew what
they were but that's not the person's
fault that's your fault
that was my because I ignored the red
flags and I saw them yes and I can lie
to myself and pretend I didn't see them
I saw them and I knew they were there
and I didn't want them to be there
I wanted this person to be differently
I've done that in my life well also too
you think you can change the person you
want people think yeah
you want a god complex because you can't
[ __ ] it's something said god complex
but it's also just hey man sometimes you
just like somebody and you want things
to be different if you want it to be
better and you don't want it to be what
it is but it is that way you don't want
to change them for them even necessarily
there's something you like them there's
just this thing that is stopping things
from working and you just want to change
that so it works you yeah right yeah but
you know I think the emotional abuse
only really kicks in when something is
being dangled above you and you feel
powerless you know I can't Chris right
right chris hardwick letting you know
who's career for not being funny but for
this okay the only thing that I think is
hurting whoa not the only thing one of
the things they think is hurting Chris
Hardwick here though is that his entire
brand and everything he does has been
built around this image of he's a great
guy right like he's always the nice guy
so I think that this thing just hurts
him in that respect I never struck me as
that guy I mean I'm not saying something
but I get maybe it is maybe I see him
from a different point of view yeah
that's I mean this whole talk show
interview style is sort of like friends
with everybody okay nice guy he's the
guy you know every girl likes him he's
the guy that everybody likes a
successful Eddie if any if it what's his
name wrong I never met the guy Bonnie
met him said money went on the date with
him with Cris Hardaway weeks ago and she
did both cheating had she say one it was
okay I mean he didn't tell her not to
drink or anything right I guess he
wanted yeah why did he go through
recovery do we know don't know about 18
years there's two sides to everything
and like when when a woman comes out and
makes allegations like that and yeah
they're serious and you got to listen
but you can't just condemn that guy
without finding out there's any truth in
it right and he had we did respond and
people didn't like his response and then
he released his text messages nerdist
taking him off it's not a big deal cuz
he wasn't with the nerdist drop a guy
like he never existed in your in your is
stupid cuz he was the founder of that
pie at least wait until the facts come
in if it comes like Cosby has been
proven guilty and went a hundred women
accuse you of something that's bad right
right I think boss I think m+ like
accident even what's the accusation here
like even if every accusation about
Chris Hardwick is true it's not rape you
know I mean so I think that AMC could
easily put him back on TV and yeah
probably should but it also depends like
you know these texts came out yesterday
afternoon
TMZ posted them they didn't talk about
who the source was but clearly this came
from Chris Hardwick I mean right of
course I hope so
right I would it has to have so who
knows if now this chick is gonna turn
around and unleash evidence maybe the
evidence is not as bad as she's making
it out to baby I have no idea cuz I get
I know nothing about her I never saw
them together right right uh let's go to
Paul in New Jersey what hello hey hey
guys a few things number one does Chris
Hardwick really have enough power to
blacklist anybody well it's not about
talent is about power when you
blacklisted he does he does nope yeah
what he had home when he had the I don't
know about blacklisting it depends on
what what part of entertainment there in
like hoodie blacklist me or Sam or
Vaught no but from that from that a lot
of the industry Shore talent shining
through - well you argue but if your
honor would never do you really want to
get pissed off on a story take a look at
Mike SOUTHCOM which is like a porno news
site and read the story under riff raff
that this girl just accused him of
trying to hook up with her and that was
it
yeah the reason he's a rap heart and
call her out on it oh thanks buddy ah
yeah riff raff is a rapper
um listen I also don't know rape yeah of
course yeah and it's not getting any
credibility something it's got any legs
so I don't know how much credence we
want to give it anyway yeah you know I
mean like if it's just on this website
who cares okay
yeah I never I know Eileen who refreshes
Plus you know his name speaks oh who he
goes I've never hated a hat more than
yours
it's really bad I hate what's under it I
hate nothing fair rich I'm sorry to hear
you
okay with that fair I wanted to control
him your fire man hey yeah Chris
basically he sent a text message you
know according to TMZ and everything
that is it's one two three four long
paragraphs and he talks about here's a
much more accurate picture but
everything that's going on particularly
with you I guess this guy Sam and I
don't know if I I think he's the guy
that she was cheating on I guess they
were going on a break but it was one of
those breaks where he didn't know that
she was gonna be hooking up with other
people and she was still with this guy
Sam right right it was like to say it
just tell us what happened you know I
don't want I'll read some of it I like
the Sam Roberts um things such a long
it's so long recently come recently
recently do sometimes just want to
actually do the entire thing do you
understand every fiber of my being wants
to read this as 11 minutes there's no
way you got it done in 11 the prior
right because I looked at wait longer I
wasn't looking at the paper and I really
thought you just read was a full line it
wasn't even half of one line
no and we're like you're looking at 1 2
3 4 100 lines out it's very very well
written and again I'm certainly not
blaming you for all of our problems I
know I'm a pain in the ass and that I
work too much and have trouble snapping
out of work mode I know that I get
insecure and frustrated easily and that
you sensed hesitation for me but I swear
on everything that I have that any
hesitation you sense for me was being in
my own head and flustered trying to
figure out how to fix it all I'm a fixer
bah bah bah bah wow that wasn't wanted I
guess penny always the best
communication and it kills me that you
honestly believe that I didn't love you
and didn't make every effort I could to
try to make you happy you know you must
know that I'm an okay guy and really did
have the best of intentions and then he
closes off with because I would have
absolutely stayed by your side and
figured this out with you yeah at a
certain point I think you
just didn't believe me because you
batted a lot of it away this is not a
guy doing damage control in the media
years later this is the actual text
you're sending to the other person from
2014 yeah this is the tech that's like
if you're in the room and you're both
discussing drapes and you're going those
are blue and she's going oh they're like
you were both addressing the same thing
this is must be how he really felt
because this is your breakup text and I
hate to tell you but guys that have a
whole bunch of jobs and a lot of them
are self-made are not fun like those
guys who like have a lot of fun jobs and
host shows and do this and do that and
are all over the place are not fun and
real didn't if he's not a funny guy I
say guy yeah people who do all this
stuff are not fun Krister consumed by
everything exactly right the idea of her
saying he said again
sexually assaulted that's a very harsh
label it is if a guy's pushy for sex or
even if he's a dick about it and goes
hey I look I like to [ __ ] a lot if you
don't want to [ __ ] even these that blunt
and callous yeah you could leave and go
that guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] but that
doesn't constitute sexual assault if
you're willingly having sex with a guy
and he's not holding anything over your
head right unless there's something
being held like if I don't do this I
won't get this job that's a different
thing but I can't do that nature its
preference dating a guy and he's just
aggressive and not even aggressive he is
once a lot of sex and you're giving it
to him because you don't want to upset
him well then stop giving it to him
because you don't upset him right if he
goes like I need more sex than you want
to give me for this relationship to work
it's okay to be like yeah this isn't
gonna work
I've argued about sex with women before
I've dated like you different times
where they've wanted it I didn't know
I've wanted it's a point of contention
with every couple what about that girl
who you were her jiggle oh yeah remember
she took you on a vacation took a
multiple vacation but the understanding
was many sexes well it's just kind of
whenever she wanted it which was
constantly older uh now she was a couple
years younger than me hot yeah love
girag money a lot of money she loved
your hog
yeah she's Asian yeah yeah okay yeah and
she just it was just then she would if I
wouldn't give it to
or you know it was like in the morning
and you just don't you know your shitty
breath and you're just kind of like look
I'm just kind of getting my head
together she would get so shitty she
gets so angry at me about it and then
she would be shitty the entire day till
we had sex
Wow good for her she paid for the
[ __ ] vacation yeah that [ __ ] hog
out and put it to work boy that was that
was a gigolo relationship so that to be
fair she's in the right Ohio there's
only so much in the well you know I mean
like you're you because you're a gigolo
doesn't mean you don't have the same
laws of your you're just a human being
exactly it don't get on the plane if you
don't have a [ __ ] look bag full of
[ __ ] now what she like a millionaire a
bunch of times over tight money money a
millionaire a bunch of times over
sentence a millionaire a bunch of times
over
did she ever but you're always into like
[ __ ] grammar but what I'm saying is
did she have a bazillion dollars exactly
he's very could she have more money hold
on aunt rich did she have more money
than God did she have so much money she
could build a rocket ship she does have
very a lot of money are you still seeing
her no mm-hmm why they take a low
lifestyle wasn't yeah does she want to
limp sexually incompetent depressive
Troy made enough money to get his tits
done and then walked away is that right
well I mean I got just got my tits done
at you pay for my tits what do you mean
you got your tattoos no I got I got cool
sculpt even get didn't it in plans
yeah it's a breast augmentation it's not
too big yeah there I got him cool
sculpted you got a cool sculpt him so
you can make him the right shape yeah
you slide a Middleton I don't need to
but yeah right here's the thing you know
it's not gonna happen I'm not getting a
fight with my wife again
so why do you fight with your wife yeah
you know why well I once wore rings huh
your four rings I get a fight with her
to say that everything how does she ever
think she's married
ass yes she goes I thought in the
beginning it was an act but it's really
[Laughter]
here's my only thing I don't think that
cool sculpt is real I think it's I think
it's I think it's fake news no it's I
definitely notice a difference already
okay oh you know what a sting though I
mean the cool thing they put around so
they they freeze it for like an hour
yeah
here's Helen it kills the fat and you
have to pay for it right yes oh yeah so
here's here's yeah the only I would have
to see your tits compared to somebody
who did not have cool sculpt I'll do
that generally now does this go
cool scope you what's it called I'm not
helping you I'm not helping you okay
let's try would you show your tits I'd
love to see the project get a cool
sculpt on me yeah I'm not talking bad
he's talking about Troy okay yeah are we
gonna compare is that what you want well
we'll get I mean maybe we'll get there I
know I'm not I'm not asking you I'm
telling you I'm not getting in a fight
tonight okay yeah you feel a little
different and then you want it pissing
it out like it's [ __ ] it freezes the
fat cells up yeah by those machines
yourself from Mexico well also be
beheaded in Mexico yeah I can't see any
difference
I can't Schneider I know what they were
like before you feel it yeah are you Jim
do you have better tits or worse tits Oh
worried yeah he's an abortion yeah what
about you worse thank you when I when I
when I'm not eating my tits are actually
not that bad anymore but I can still I
could still go for it he has like you
know what like your you have definition
so if you just yeah you feel like it
just becomes muscle and it really looks
like this we're we're supposed to if you
have most of that oh you don't want much
you want it flat yeah see minor minor
like bosoms do you want put my chest
guide you get poked how do you feel it's
not bad but they're like tits well you
can't tell washer doc come on Ritchie
already let me tell you I'm not getting
in a fight you don't know the fight I
had last time
tell me about where's the fight what you
empty [ __ ] loser let me take your
shirt off your 61 year old man stop I
can't handle I'm not listening once
y'all look like you're 61 you look good
yeah you're not an MRI let me tell you
something what does that mean if you
can't see the insides that was pretty I
don't know here's an MRI he's a
monumentally rotten idiot hey guys the
summer sun's out guns out let's take
it's not good let's see it we've never
seen it stand next to him when your
shirt off but there's no reason for me
to do it I don't work on they don't care
about your [ __ ] you know torso looks
okay if you don't care then that's no
problem I've seen it looks like did you
ever see a [ __ ] a hazard bag with
bloodless description you're actually in
better shape than I think no I don't
think so yeah I know I think that you're
in better shape in Troy I don't think
Roger boss is in better shape than you I
I think you can't compare it's like
comparing well you can compare no you
can't because I'm alright so no one to
case closed listen I know you guys are
trying let's go to the Keith [ __ ]
bombing video it's gonna be a lot better
I'll tell you what no I make you deal
there's no deal if you give me five
topless seconds and the listeners it's
only fair because Jim wants to hear
Keith I want to hear Keith listeners
want to hear people hey Travis do you
want to hear the Keith Robinson stuff
yeah but we can't get to that we can't
no we didn't tell this is 95 topless
Addison Travis you [ __ ] follower used
to be a leader travi travi is a great
leader exactly Travis was a leader hey
kid get out if I don't say that here's
what I here's what I'll do for you guys
tell me next time I come in yeah I won't
eat plus I ate and I'm
[Music]
party in my direction you spit food yeah
I yes I didn't think I had any left
oh so next time I come in I'll do it for
the last time I just need a ton more
weeks no I need we need to get paired
and contrasting their before and after I
mean you both act 7 mean I know
something it was something he would
insult a comic with it a roast in the
early 2000 almost [ __ ] my god last night
would you stayed in it no it had their
cleaner I fire I felt the gasser and the
liquid came right and right to the end I
in my bed last night I had to run to the
toilet I live I almost shot my tub of
course that's disgusting a new adventure
it just happened don't tell you somebody
with somebody over earlier I drank a lot
of vegetable juice I did I drank two
giant vegetable juices do you mic is on
just write it down you're terrible
whisper I don't know what you're gonna
say just write it down you'll want to
bring something that's no it's not bad
you have a pass right what are you gonna
write down rich just don't say it okay
he's writing okay
I'm writing an essay it's goddamn Chris
Hardwick text it really is
it's it's uh what are we thinking yeah
you talked about it oh yeah why are you
writing that down like that talked about
what okay what is secret what's the non
secret the Jews control the media
[Laughter]
nicotine punch we did talk about of
course I did what was your story about
that depalo oh maybe he talked about
money oh yeah of course yeah yeah we did
yeah apparently he got punched at levity
live right I don't know where I'm wrong
I guess it's some woman at the end
punched him after the show I mean
the way I heard the story was he was
doing his pictures and you know
merchants whatever after at levity live
in the Palisades and a girl came up to
take a photo with him and one of her
parents punched him
no she punched him what was on the
parents or maybe one of the parents took
the photo and she punched him yeah and
just something that's otherwise I think
the dad was taking a photo and the
daughter punched him why yeah did he
ever arrested for assault I think some
cops came out because my daughter wants
to that's when the guy came over to him
and told me he loved the show editing
but my daughter wants to punch you in
the face it was at that moment the man's
daughter sucker-punched Nick hitting him
right below his left thigh he didn't
finish the word face and she
sucker-punched me Nick told Bennington's
Nick did nothing in response to ask the
guy whether this had been a setup he did
call the police to have a report of the
incident made yeah of course he'll be
the poster girl for Occupy Wall Street
and his self-righteous little [ __ ] he
said the world doesn't allow him to hit
back he'll take it to court good he
should yeah 100%
I hope Nick presses full charges on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] I do a hundred percent
so what happen when people feel like
there's no consequence yeah you have a
[ __ ] brat little spoiled brat you
don't like Nick's point of view go [ __ ]
yourself get up and leave the show baby
yeah that's [ __ ] you're not entitled
to [ __ ] punch Nick in the face cuz
you think he's ever terrible person you
don't like his jokes go [ __ ] yourself
you don't like [ __ ] Hamilton you're
gonna go [ __ ] knockout you know go
[ __ ] I held on what was his name
I know what his name was to you yeah
yeah you go knock out the star we got a
nick in Detroit my god what is your
lowest rate okay Nick what's going on
gentlemen
the goal today has been absolutely great
thank you I just have one request that
you might um I want to see if we can get
a legend rich boss to take your shirt
off on today's shorter make my morning
richest time
Richie Richie imagine all the people
around the world that will buy your
roast once you take your shirt off and
you know and you entertain the millions
of people listening to the show right
now Richie we are truly to hear you we
all turn into laughs to be entertained
to be happy all we want you to do which
is to take your shirt off for us please
buddy
many people will buy that roast it was
thank you very much how many people will
buy that roast if vos does that because
honestly yeah people buy the roast
let me go to Miguel in Los Angeles
what's up Miguel hey good morning guys
good morning hey I'm contemplating about
buying the VAS roast or not but if rich
takes off your shirt I'll buy it buy it
not rent it buy it first why that you
wouldn't take off your shirt for all
these people that are gonna buy the
thing I like - I don't think this guy
can buy the wait for you'll buy it I
will buy it tonight that's three that's
three sales right now have you take your
shirt off - and you're gonna buy it
that's a deal I was there I'm not gonna
buy it but that's four I'll come I'll
see how the sales went up from today see
is that we know no it's not you know
what you don't do yeah I would gladly
give you a dollar tomorrow for a
hamburger today no that's the opposite
you know they're gonna buy it right now
Randall I know that it's an even look at
the sales figures
you can't come back next week anyway
we're all booked
we got a solid week of our shows let me
see Bobby mark norm yeah Joe Maki Maki
yeah
that's so soda yeah but you go Chris
yeah Lucy Gomez to Gomez coming
yeah very big week to comic book Quinn
Colin Quinn
[ __ ] you one call on this show that's
right
brilliant Miguel you'll buy this special
if vos takes his shirt off rich come on
if you don't do it I'm listening
let's go to Paul in New Jersey with a
shirt off rich good morning guys what's
going on
morning Paul hey me this 100% I will buy
the rules the boss dude now people are
doing it for real people love it when
you take your shirt off and they will
buy the road it's funny and you're gonna
hear [ __ ] about that later the speed at
which you changes here's my favorite
moment is this you know I don't want
this when he gets off the seat and you
know it's about don't take any [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that rich you'll go with your shirt
off yeah let's get that video up on
social a set but I'm in shock I gotta
leave at 10:30
why and this is for real because I have
to check out my hotel by 11:00 and my
luggage is in there oh then my room
awesome awesome
my bad you took your shirt off I paid
300 [ __ ] dollars to come into New
York today well I'm gonna tell you this
you're gonna get a lot more money than
that from sales of this vodka everybody
I'm not gonna buy yes of course they
will you took your shirt off boss took
his shirt off that's the deal that means
Troy Travie you actually had already
purchased it correct okay that that but
that counts
yeah Troy and Travis you have to buy
today I'll buy
I have not you had already purchased it
okay okay so that can't still counts to
the tunnel on that mug and I'll do it
you're gonna do it
Troy you're gonna buy it absolutely okay
you made the deal Miguel's gonna buy if
Paul's gonna buy it you know we can try
it I don't want to buy here 20 that's
for me and not that's remain Sam feels
like prostitution yeah how'd you get
that offered me a hundred bucks ago I
don't like your [ __ ] money there's a
guest fee yeah but I would have taken it
oh no I don't look good in that yes you
do look how fat I look no down it's like
a Mapplethorpe photo Troy I gotta get a
better picture are you take you Rob
where's Rob we need to do it take two
yeah yeah yeah we're doing it take two
but yeah we got it we had to get it take
two because we didn't like rich didn't
like the way look in the first yeah he
does have really good [ __ ] insect abs
do you think that do you think that did
the fact that he had to do a second one
do you think the fact that he had to
take a second one is gonna make Bonnie
think he's more empty or less empty if
she and me mad about that see that one
doesn't look look Evie in that no you
know what he looks really good in that
you don't worry she just to be on the
safe side you'll push both right now I
would never do it again
okay well that's already out let me show
it looks good
they're both good oh what's that fog
holy [ __ ] what is in [ __ ] great shape
he's in great shape it really annoys me
that's why we like seeing him without
his shirt on I really wanted a [ __ ]
picture he look terrible in this not
sucker has ADD he's got abs and
everything in that sentence is accurate
yeah yeah
you could post the second one and say
correction this is what vos looks like
my wife leaves me at least I need
something to line something up that's
right no you're right look anybody tried
to create a grinder account for him
that's right anybody that thinks that
this is the the joke here the vas isn't
in good shape does not understand
anything because what is in good shape
that's why I like seeing you with you
you're in amazing shape that's the whole
point no not that picture what I had the
picture that I just saw that Troy took
you can see your abs you can yes sure
loss that's a six-pack it annoys you but
look at the pectorals yeah hey what do
you think boss for you no don't shake
that's really cool laughs of washing
himself because imagine if you had to go
home and he's like ok Bonnie today on
the radio show I took off my shirt twice
and then I shadow you're an insane shape
yeah yeah that's that that in all
honesty that's a urine Gration yeah your
wife should not be upset about that your
wife should be thrilled that that's what
she married yeah quite frankly yeah was
that you rich and of course it was rich
here is Danny up he's talking about
jokes let's go to Rodney talking to the
man wait how do you think you see it
yeah sure oh man all these fart I know
something's leading up let's go to
Rodney in Texas Rodney okay can we get
an epic photo of the four legends in the
room taking their shirts off all
together please no unfortunately not no
unfortunately not
no I'm not in good enough shape yeah I'm
just honest of us like punching down
what is dude you just took a great
topless picture I know we were laughing
at stuff before what do you mean you
have nothing don't get that on
yourselves you don't have it Tim's good
you had something good yeah it's pretty
good I think good ones yeah I'm pretty
impressed with that one right right if
you go to at Jim and Sam Joe
it does look like thinning yeah it guys
consider hat no it's not the follicles
you think that's what it is see from
here well the photos up on at Jim and
Sam show on Twitter and reported on
Instagram too right yes yeah does that
look bad you look great honestly shape
the meat it will post them both yeah
young good [ __ ] sorry up there it
doesn't matter who keep you in shape
Dodos the other ones are the ones that
people are gonna [ __ ] Photoshop
dolphins head on my [ __ ] whatever it's
often ahead why I don't know it's just
the first thing that came to my mind so
there's no idea why would they do that
to a dolphin player you're killing it
right rich yeah yeah what do you mean
I'm killing it you're doing a great job
really I can't tell you how much I
appreciate that you did that I do it for
you I know because it you know makes me
laugh so much you know it's so much fun
for me I love it when you do it and I
really appreciate that you do it you
don't know that I'm gonna get in a fight
over this that's part of the reason why
I like it so much because now it's like
there's a whole other element it's not
just rich has no shirt on it's oh my god
this is so funny because Bonnie's gonna
be so upset with him right I need that
picture for Grindr
what's she gonna say to you know those
my flower tats look pretty I don't want
the SiriusXM on grindy if they lock that
out yeah and don't put our show name
either you're not into it it's a
microphone rigging into a TV monitor
electronics the micro I'm not trying to
be a dick from the he gets in front of
the mic and he stops looking from the
flower on flower to the neck how about a
moose
Oh put some flowers do you think it'll
work
what do you think Barney's gonna say to
you huh what do you think Ronnie's gonna
say to you
you're [ __ ] you're just an old empty
[ __ ] soul why do you do it for their
pleasure you're [ __ ] your ass while
you stand up you're going right you're a
bait you're a [ __ ] major actor you're
alleging you don't need to do that for a
laugh and I tell her you're right and
but I can't say no to my buddy thank you
it's just you know it's fine it's just a
fun time and look here's here's good
news right here Joe and Virginia how do
you do Joe what what oh man I missed it
hang on for a sec Joe the boss had some
kind of headphone error that I was
looking at the phone screen for I'm
gonna need Jim to explain what you said
Oh Travis did you see it no I was
reading the replies on a pitch he picked
well here's we got a camera oh yeah
right on him
he picked the [ __ ] camera is there a
way we can go back and get that in the
commercial break I mean as soon as we
got a break he can watch it dude he hit
picked it up look I think he come in to
see the time on so we know exactly how
far back to go and he picked the
headphone up to hear it and he hit
himself right in the [ __ ] head oh
that's amazing
by the way we're already getting tweets
from people that are buying it and
screen capping their receipts boss is a
[ __ ] trooper yeah and and the roast
is hellenic truly hilariously you
probably should have bought it anyway
but go ahead Joe
I was gonna say I rented it and now I've
got to [ __ ] buy it because I kept
rewinding it and I'm gonna run out of
time it's really I've got Florentine
took a [ __ ] beating yes see we're
sorry about you see with the timecode
really funny see there it is Joe is now
going to buy it everybody's buying the
Viceroy everyone you know I wait
everyone [ __ ] killed Voss roast
common box and it's [ __ ] five bucks
just to rent it if you only want to
watch it once and I just you know it's
funny man and var Stoke his shirt off
for you oh no no no no what this isn't
great no I don't stop at mentioning
Bonnie cuz she's gonna see it yeah
because that in a reply to the tweet
with
with no shirt on somebody wrote nobody
tell at Bonnie McFarlane she might get
mad that's not good that's not good
there's a there's a few of them accident
no one ain't yes it is was good one
it's good it's good I want a good one
yeah all right look gonna buy the DVD
now yeah yeah we do need to at some
point we should have Bonnie in studio to
ask why she's got a problem with Bostick
oh by the way speaking of people with a
problem with boss I wasn't really a
problem but when Mike cannon was in here
on last Friday you were not here yeah I
was off joking
but he said I was congratulating him on
getting up at the Comedy Cellar and he
said yeah it was just like it was dumb
luck and this person stepped out and he
said I would have had a half-hour but
vas insisted on taking ten of my minutes
well not at the Comedy Cellar and he
said right you don't do a half an hour
nobody should have to sell it did I get
that story wrong Travis if in the stand
he said it may have been the stand
somewhere probably the stand and I
probably had needed to do ten minutes
for something sure yeah and the fact and
I hear he's a funny guy and the CD is
good but if Rick DeVos wants to do
[ __ ] 10min that's right that's what
the [ __ ] you got a deal with right
that's you know what room what fact
you're like I didn't do your whole half
an hour you grow a beard and all of a
sudden you're a headliner
go [ __ ] yourself I hear he's funny I
have nothing bad to say but there was a
reason I had to do it I don't know if he
actually had a problem with it or not he
just brought it up and I thought it was
funny oh oh he wasn't mad he didn't see
no he's just like yeah I was gonna do 30
but the boss had to do to get my cannons
new CD it's [ __ ] very good no he's a
real funny guy he's very we have money's
very very funny yeah I never heard him
once you know he's funny other radio
know he's funny I don't know is that but
he's funny he knows on fire podcast ik
this kid Jefferson
yeah this kid Jeffery yeah yeah like he
sold out two shows at the underground
off
females females only yeah there's some
relations what is she [ __ ] Jenny
Jones but he got all [ __ ] - James
Jones illa 96 used to do a show with all
females on tour that's why she got
famous - did no males allow that Oh when
Sally chippy Raphael did you Jenny Jones
hasn't been any like nobody knows her
for 20 years brings up all references
here so Jones all female audience yes
yeah that's how she got famous I know
that but just a while ago you know I
think she had breast cancer I think she
lost her breasts which any more facts
fun facts with rich yeah